Brandenburg an der Havel eine Stadt mit
72.000 Einwohnern im Norden ein
Wohngebiet der Baugenossenschaft hier
leben Familien mit wenig Geld und viele
Rentner steigende Energiepreise sind für
viele kaum zu verkraften
sandra wiedike hat zwei Kinder lebt
gerade von Elterngeld und ab Oktober
muss sie 150 Euro im Monat mehr zahlen
allein fürs Heizen
und wenn man dann halt von meinem
Elterngeld die Mieter bezahlt die
Versicherung die Kita-Gebühren Benzin
dann weiß man es bleibt nichts mehr
übrig und man kann aber auch nicht sagen
man spart an Heizkosten wir haben halt
zwei kleine Kinder wir können nicht
sagen wir machen jetzt den ganzen Winter
die Heizung nicht mehr an die meine
Kleine die fängt dann an zu krabbeln der
große der ist auch nur unterwegs ist die
Wohnung muss warm sein dass die Leute es
warm haben das ist der Job von
Stadtwerke-Chef Gunther Haase noch ist
wohnen in dieser Gegend bezahlbar
die Sorge dass durch die steigenden
Energiekosten diese moderaten Mietpreise
aufgefressen werden durch die Energie
und damit wir hier
sozial ein Problem bekommen ist
natürlich sehr groß bei uns
Gunther Hase steckt in der Klemme die
Gaspreise sind massiv gestiegen die
müsse er am Ende an seiner 12.000 Kunden
durchreichen
wir haben also Preissprünge von über 200
300 Prozent in den Märkten Strom und Gas
gesehen in dieser Größenordnung kann man
das noch nie wahrgenommen ich bin hier
seit Ewigkeiten in diesem Unternehmen
hatte bis vor einem Jahr richtig Freude
an meiner Arbeit aber die bröckelt jetzt
für gunterhase ist die Welt aus den
Fugen geraten jahrelang liefen die
Geschäfte in seinem Büro an der Havel
bestens bis zu 8 Millionen Euro gewinnen
konnte Hase der Stadt Brandenburg
jährlich überweisen das war nur möglich
in Abhängigkeit von günstigem russischem
Gas
so haben das alle gemacht sagt Hase
jetzt kommt die Quittung davon ist
Professor flassig von der Technischen
Hochschule Brandenburg überzeugt
[Musik]
weil es im Prinzip in so einer
wohlfühlblase eingeschlummert und es
geht sehr gut es kommt alles günstig
rein und es war kein Bedarf kein Signal
durch den Preis und das sehen wir jetzt
hier mitten in der Stadt da am
Fachbereich Energieeffizienz rechnen sie
durch wie die Strom- und Wärmeversorgung
der Zukunft aussehen könnte und das ohne
russisches Gas das ist einfach dass man
in mehreren Dimensionen denkt und ihm
nicht einfach nur auf die Rendite schaut
dass man eben sagt okay welche
Technologie wählen wir dass wir
zukunftsfähig sind eine Idee Abwärme aus
der Industrie nutzen das ehemalige
stahlkombinat zu DDR-Zeiten wichtigste
Arbeitgeber der Region heute wird hier
immer noch Stahl produziert dabei fällt
viel wärmer an wir haben das uns mal
angeguckt knappen Fünftel könnte man
leistungstechnisch thermisch aus den
Stahlwerken auskoppeln für die für den
Wärmebedarf in Brandenburg ja und das
tolle an einer Abwärme Nutzung ist
natürlich immer Produkt plus Abwärme
versus das alte denken das Produkt und
die Abwehr geht in die Luft
die Firma Schlote im Südwesten der Stadt
hier setzen Sie die Idee mit der Abwärme
schon um der Autozulieferer stellt
Getriebegehäuse her auch hier schlägt
die Energiekrise voll zu 4 Millionen
Euro mehr für Strom alleine in diesem
Jahr aber zumindest wird bei Schlote
schon seit einem Jahr kein Gas mehr für
die Wärme verfeuert um die
Produktionshallen zu heizen dafür nutzt
die Firma die Abwärme ihrer Anlagen eine
Strategie für die ganze Stadt
Brandenburg mein Firmenchef Jürgen
Schlote
meine persönliche Überzeugung ist die
dass wenn wir mit intelligenter
Technologie an die Themen rangehen wir
durchaus in der Lage sind
autark zu werden und dazu gehört dann
zum Beispiel die Nutzung von Wärme die
heute ungenutzt im Stahlwerk verloren
geht aber umgewandelt werden könnte
diese Krise wird sicherlich auch als
Booster wirken für diese Themen
Abwärme aus dem Stahlwerk hat
Stadtwerke-Chef Gunther Haase eine große
Chance für mehr Unabhängigkeit vom Gas
verpasst Hase winkt ab das
wärmepotenzial sei zwar da aber keine
Versorgungssicherheit heißt konkret wenn
das Stahlwerk nicht produziert fließt
durch seine Netze keine Wärme so geht es
für Hase also nicht was dann wir haben
für uns geguckt welche Lösung die beste
aus wirtschaftlichen und ökologischen
Gesichtspunkten ist und haben uns für
die Anbindung an die Fernwärmeleitung in
Premnitz entschieden da wir natürlich
hier schon vorhandene Abwärme nutzen
Premnitz 20 Kilometer nördlich von
Brandenburg hier steht eine der größten
Müllverbrennungsanlagen Deutschlands
schon seit sieben Jahren laufen die
Planungen von hier die Wärme für die
Stadt Brandenburg zu beschaffen der
Stadtwerke Manager ist überzeugt hier
findet er was er sucht
Versorgungssicherheit denn Müll gäbe es
ohne Ende und mit der Müllverbrennung
könne er preiswert Wärme liefern Hase
ist sich sicher hier wird das Feuer nie
erlöschen
wir sind im Grunde in der Lage den
Großteil der Stadt Brandenburg über
diese große Distanz von 20 Kilometern
mit Energie zu versorgen
die Rohre für die Wärme aus der
Müllverbrennung sind zwar schon da aber
noch nicht angeschlossen am
Heizkraftwerk in Brandenburg an der
Havel bis hier kein Gas mehr verbrannt
wird kann es noch ein Jahr dauern
für Sandra wiedecke eine lange Zeit sie
ist wie viele andere wegen der
Energiekrise auf Hilfe vom Staat
angewiesen und die reiche hinten und
vorne nicht
also ganz ehrlich diese 300 Euro
Einmalzahlung ist für den Monat zwar
ganz nett aber wie gesagt wir reden ja
von einem Zustand der sich ja über
mehrere Monate Jahre ziehen wird und da
bringt eigentlich eine Einmalzahlung von
300 Euro für Familien nicht viel
eine Stadt ein ganzes Land in der
Energiefalle hier an der Hochschule sind
sie überzeugt viele Stadtwerke hätten zu
lange auf alte Technik und Rezepte
gesetzt für die Wissenschaftler ist die
Sache klar
die klassischen Stadtwerke machen ist
die fossile Energie wird einfach
verfeuert ja ob es jetzt ölgas Kohle ist
oder Müll völlig egal das ist fossilen
Energie die wird einfach verfeuert was
ich jetzt machen kann ich kann sagen
okay ich setze ihn nicht mehr auf diese
alte Technologie sondern ich frage was
kommt denn jetzt in Zukunft in Frage
Stichwort Selbstversorgung und da muss
ich auf Energieträger setzen wo ich
letztlich auch grün grüne Energie
einkoppeln kann und das kann eben nicht
das Gas oder das Öl oder der Müll sein
das muss koppelfähig sein an den grünen
Strom den wir hier in Deutschland
generieren können also zum Beispiel viel
mehr Foto Voltaik eine Studie der
Hochschule hat ergeben auf Brandenburgs
Dechant schlummert ein strompotenzial
für 200.000 Bürger bisher sind nur erste
zarte versuche zu sehen auch hier in
Brandenburg Nord
aber die allermeisten Dächer sind leer
viele davon gehören der städtischen
Wohnungsbaugenossenschaft wir sind hier
sicherlich an der Stelle dass die
konservativ gewesen
wir wollen uns dem Thema jetzt stellen
das wäre mehr Sonne auf die Dächer ob
man das als mieterstrom nutzt oder zur
Heizungsunterstützung nutzt da gibt es
verschiedene Möglichkeiten das
haben wir uns als Aufgabe eben jetzt
vorgenommen auf jeden Dach was wir
anfassen auch das wird dauern in diesem
Herbst und Winter hat Matthias Osterburg
ganz andere Sorgen er muss die Leute im
Viertel davon abhalten mit Strom zu
heizen weil Gas so teuer ist
Worst Case wäre wenn die Stadtwerke kein
Gas mehr bekommen und die Wärme nicht
mehr erzeugen können und wir die Wohnung
nicht mehr beheizen
zweiter Teil wäre wenn die
Fernwärmeleitung aus Premnitz zur
Heizsaison 23 24 immer noch nicht zur
Verfügung Stunde
in der Energie-
wir ziehen uns wirklich also als Mitte
der Gesellschaft vom Einkommen her
fallen in der jetzigen Zeit haben viele
das Gefühl ich in dem Fall auch dass die
Mitte immer weiter runter rutscht und
dass man halt sehen muss wo man bleibt
Brandenburg an der Havel eine Stadt wie
viele in Deutschland vor dem ersten
Winter ohne russisches Gas wir in alten
Zeiten